Allen starts off this hour in Kentucky
hey Allen welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show bad Dave I Chris it's harder to get
to speak to both of you all today
you too sir um my question today Momo
I'm 52 years old my life's 50 and we've
got 10 year old son I was laid off in
the middle of March due to lack of work
we're at my employer because the cold
was 19 and subsequently I've lost my job
there since that time and right now
money that I have coming in is are my
state unemployment benefits federal
unemployment benefits I get money from a
beneficiary IRA and a beneficiary
annuity my wife's income is stable and
has been throughout the pandemic when I
was laid off we started saving cash on
that cash and at the moment and we've
been paying our minimum payment on
everything if we were debt-free at this
point we'd have about three or four
months of expenses saved up for a baby
step three got a chance come maybe have
like six months saved up by the end of
July but my question is should we at
this point go ahead and continue to save
cash personally start paying on our debt
what does she make sheet last year it
was around 47 or do you wish to make
Meister my 29 and then I had some like
that get a minimum distributions from a
Fisher high rate annuity yeah I know
that by me your at your career you were
making 30 grand yes and you lost that
job so how's the job hunt going
well because we've got a 10 year old we
and Kentucky you we're not as far as
been able to get you know day camps and
daycares and stuff and I actually open
them back up till next week and during
the summer months that's what we would
do with our son he would typically go to
you know two different they cancel and
stuff throughout the summer a lot of
them are still on hold because of Kovac
well you know you haven't even talked
direct Department pardon so you haven't
even looked
no okay when you gonna start looking
potentially when school starts back up
in August why you don't think the day
camps are gonna open
we well out of the ones that he goes to
I've not been able to find out any
information on him okay
well I'd be concerned about getting back
in the getting back in the saddle if I
were in your shoes I mean July 25th is
unemployment runs out and you're gonna
be you're gonna want to be getting back
to normal before you stop powder stop
stop piling up cash I think yeah I do
too Alan I mean you are aware that in
July that extra six hundred a week goes
away right yeah okay and so you being
proactive right now I mean do you guys
have family members where you live um we
do okay cuz see that's where stepping
out of the box and you start to look and
you think and your kid go over there
while you're working
but jump-starting it that's my fear Alan
is that a lot of people are sitting back
and waiting until the end of July to
start to be concerned and the time to be
concerned is now the time to be
proactive is now so you you can put
yourself in a better situation before
the money runs out otherwise there's
going to be this glut out there Dave of
a lot of people that are trying to
jumpstart something that could have been
an easier start earlier we have 40
million unemployed the ones that are on
unemployment are all gonna be looking
for work July the 25th yeah I would get
a jump ahead of that line I don't want
to be in line behind 40 million people
that's exactly right and as you look for
a job it might not be in your area of
choice it doesn't matter David heard you
say this years ago it's easier to find a
job when you have one yeah and so get
some money coming in because it'll just
change your psyche yeah I want you to
detain the answer your question is I
want you get stabilized on the career
side before you stop piling up cash
because I don't want you to come up
short and I'm worried that your
strategy's going to cause you to be
unemployed past when you think you're
going to UM it sounds like you think
there's gonna be no problem as soon as
the childcare thing straightens out or
he goes back to school then it'd be no
problem just picking up a job which the
good news is you make thirty thousand
dollars a year
300,000 those are harder to find so
30,000 is easier to find so I you know
that's that's the thing I would get
after and I want to get in line in front
of all these people that are gonna wait
oh absolutely
and this is the time to dust off your
resume start reaching out to people
friends co-workers let people know that
you are looking don't be so picky right
now that you pick yourself out of an
option yeah yeah I think I'd be a little
more urgent than if I were in your shoes
then you've been on this so far hey man
thanks for the call